tutto è finalmente tornato per voi per
capire come migliorare il mondo perché
il mondo necessita di dottore in questo
preciso momento
oggi esperimento per un'umanità essere
inferiore vedere da basito torre
ingredienti per cose ma non ne sono in
cadenti essere risultati finali di
accurata evoluzione umana dottore cuore
domanda voi esseri inferiori prestare
attenzione e risposte difficili quale
elemento non potrebbe essere fatto con
patate complimenti e il 4 sbagliata
tutti elementi potrebbe essere fatti
compattati compreso slime
[Musica]
oggi scoprire condotto per farle slide
da cutoff in sabina
certo con la torre di cut off e con
territori di cannes offre incollata pete
è vista una volta affettata cartofer
cutoff entrare perfettamente dentro
frullatore guerra comincia
[Musica]
niente di più bello di cut off e
putrefatta uscire fumo molto strano dal
frullatore non capire se esplosioni
imminente sì perché non aggiungerò a
lottare molto molto impaurito offerta
quando è grata
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sulla torre distrutto dottore aver
dovuto tagliare tutto a mano perché
frullatore esploso spetta a pezzi prima
ammuffite perché passato 789 no sicuro
di quello che succede però dottore molto
più guardo di quanto pensato tra base di
patate completando più o meno una volta
raggiunto questo risultato and her
brocca d'acqua versare acqua dottore a
cingere a mescolare come vecchia strega
saldamente miscuglio e versarle in nuova
teca per separare mesi di bagarre da dal
succo di patata aspettare a dieci minuti
per fermentazioni di patate
[Musica]
una volta che attesa è finita sul fondo
di nostro contenitore esserci cosa
bianca che voi non vedere inserire acqua
dove versare contenuto finale dentro può
essere molto esperto di queste cose non
centrare una volta chiuso contenitore
ahearn eticamente schierare c'è chi
cercherà come pelosi una volta terminato
lo shaker e lasciar fermentare per 10
minuti prendere aver preparato dopo che
dieci minuti sono passati versare acqua
in eccesso e service line mostra e
sperabilmente sarei quasi completato
perché slime server quasi completamente
riuscito come vedere ma bisogna
aspettare due giorni
[Musica]
passati due giorni dottore fissato muro
come potete vedere il risultato essere
molto secco la soluzione di per top l'ha
fatta diventare polverina dottore è
finito di scavare dottore fatto un sacco
di pratica su gioco con tanti pixel 9
cordon o meno a fotonica servire per
dare effetto finale il magico a paul
vernaci aggiungere risultato
soddisfacente
vediamo quindi il risultato finale degli
esperimenti siamo finalmente arrivati a
termine di riferimento lopez live essere
creato un mito ha creato inservienti
creato porre prendere carafa e versare
sul tavolo di inservienti nuovo slime
che poi inservienti pulire vedere cruise
line essere molto liquido mento scendere
ma quando poggiarsi per terra toga
potere partito così totò riprendere
pezzo e fa vedere consistenza
[Musica]
line essere creato la fecola di patate
proprietà che renderà il liquido
schifoso
adesso totò rilanciare voi sfida voglio
avere instagram poi fare video ventre
ripetere esperimento quando fare video
calcare su instagram utilizzare astag
esperimenti incredibile targate che
povero toppe in prossimo episodio fare
riesce dove non aiuterà utilizzare lista
grandi quello come chiamarsi youtuber
quello falso letto quel youtuber senza
talento prestare instagram è dottore
episodio poter concludersi quanto attore
necessità petit vasca da bagno
noi vederci in un prossimo episodio di
esperimenti incredibile 6 di due pc di
lasciare mi piace e andate in pace
[Musica]
no